Matthew you play a character called a
visa Steve in this film don't you use
the brother of one of the lead
characters now what was it like kind of
getting into the head of a beaver Steve
he's a bit of a character to say the
least is new yeah I think getting into
it into his head started when they put
the extensions in my hair because I had
like curtains you know that went down to
where and that was like as soon as they
got them in I was in the nineties again
and that excited curtains when I was
younger as well and and bought getting
it getting to know someone that I mean I
I know a few people like you be for
state so we had references to use um but
he's a bit of a bit of an [ __ ] list
but you know I mean I think at the time
I think people in the night is in any
Manchester it started life was probably
a bit a bit [ __ ] to be honest and then
so any opportunity to escape from that
you know drugs drink a beefer it would
you know you thought I didn't go for it
you know and you don't really think
about the consequences because there
wasn't much consequence so what you did
because nothing was as you know it was
it couldn't get any worse yeah I mean so
and well I be first day I mean it was a
good a great character to play yeah what
made that period kind of stand out for
you as well and what sort of memories do
you have of that time I think they're
well they're for a start like the
curtains and all that and then the
clothes as well I think to be on it when
he got so nineties everything had been
done by the looks of it and then
anything what everyone in the night is
we're trying to be original just start
what's left you know and no one had done
mushroom haircuts no one had done
curtains and no one had wash bright
shell suits and baggy t-shirt so it I
think it's the clothes and it's the
whole sort of style of the time is it's
pretty unique it's a ski finally what
are you up to next Matthew I'm doing
I've just I've just finished on the
Paradise and then I'm doing choir at the
last Paro
and they're doing a BBC one-off drama
and then hopefully I'll do some fair
you